[Applause]
[Music]
emmanuel macron
seems like the perfect politician who
appeals to pretty much everyone he's
just progressive enough to charm
hollywood actors and
libertarian enough to seduce wall street
sharks outside france
everyone wants to take a selfie with
macron inside france however it's an
altogether different story check this
out
fires erupt in paris as general strike
creates travel nightmare
closing the eiffel tower and subway
stations fox news
this new story is from weeks before the
tsar's covert ii pandemic hit the media
and in theory this story is really not
so surprising violent riots are as
common in france as croissants and
menage trois
but the question is why are they
protesting this time well
it's nothing less than pension reform
[Music]
let's state this clearly both france and
spain have a very serious problem with
their pension system both countries have
a pay-as-you-go system where workers pay
the pension of retirees
fewer and fewer young people are
contributing and more and more all
people are receiving their pensions the
system is on the verge of collapse
and it's here that you realize that
pensions have something in common with
the coronavirus pandemic
both are very serious problems which
could collapse an entire country the
collapse of pensions is not just any
problem
it is the problem both in france and in
spain but few politicians want to talk
about it seriously because all solutions
involve
unpopular measures just as no politician
wants to force his or her citizens into
lockdown no politician wants to say that
there is no more money
for your pension
[Music]
and believe me pensions and friends are
in need of reform to give you an idea we
are talking about the most generous
pensions in the world
french retirees receive an average 61 of
their last salary while in germany they
receive only 38
in fact the oecd average is 49 what's
more the french retirement age for
receiving a pension without penalty
is set at 62 years by comparison in
spain it's 65 but it's already on the
way to 67 as set by the previous
socialist government out of interest
67 is a retirement age in germany and i
know now what many of you are thinking
so macron wants to lower pensions and
raise the retirement age but nothing of
the sort macron's pension reform doesn't
even go that far it neither touches the
retirement age nor
does it touch pensions so the question
is what's the problem then why are these
pension reforms
so controversial and more importantly
world macron reforms set to address the
pension problem
in europe today we're going to answer
all of these questions
[Music]
vestiges of the sun king
in the last 400 years france has gone
from the sun king from the most absolute
absolutism to having one of the
strongest democracies
in the world however there is something
that is not often mentioned the absolute
king of france was not the only person
with privileges behind him there was a
whole court of nobles officials
and workers who also lived much better
lives than the common people and then
came the french revolution the people
seized power under the banner of liberty
equality and fraternity
v la france and here comes the part that
doesn't make it into the history books
yes
it is true the revolutionaries cut off
the head of the king and so many others
but you cannot build a new country by
killing all the elites that ruled it
before so
the revolution came and went but there
were elite collectives that managed to
keep their privileges and not only for a
few
years i'm talking about privileges that
continue to this day there is the core
de ballet and the workers of the paris
opera who've enjoyed a special
retirement regime since
1698. that's right 1698. this is why in
the 21st century we can read news
stories
like this one the paris opera on strike
to defend the pensions of louis xiv
fr24 so what privilege did the sun king
grant the dancers nothing less than the
right to retire at 42 years of age and
yes
i know that dance is a very demanding
art form and pushes the human body to
the extreme you should just see me in
nightclubs but there are two things i
should want to tell you one the medicine
has advanced just a little in the last
three centuries and i imagine something
would be able to done to relieve the
dancers and the second thing is that the
workers of the opera of nice or bordeaux
are not eligible for this special
retirement sheet
because it only benefits the dancers who
entertained the sun king
400 years ago that is those working at
the paris opera in other words this
is a textbook privilege a privilege that
comes from as far back as before the
french revolution but wait a minute
because they're not the only ones
[Music]
[Applause]
the state-owned french railway company
or sncf operates the railway sector
under a monopoly its workers are
considered the most privileged in france
they can retire with two-thirds of their
salary at the age of 50. under a special
scheme dating back to when train drivers
had to shovel coal although their
retirement age will rise to 52 in 2024
their workers will continue to work a
decade
less than other french workers
but in the end this is nothing to be
surprised about after all there are up
to 42 different special pension schemes
as you can see granting privileges is in
the french
dna it makes no difference whether the
governing system is a democracy an
absolute monarch
or an emperor something similar happened
in the mid 20th century when the welfare
state was established as we always say
on visualpolitik the devil is in the
details the problem is not the welfare
state itself but what kind of welfare
state it is
and the latest one an egalitarian one
for example the welfare state in nordic
countries such as sweden is very
generous to anyone who is a citizen of
the country however its civil servants
do not have special privileges as in the
case in other european countries they
are considered middle class and it is
not considered
appropriate that they should have those
privileges all this makes sense if we
take into account the forefathers of the
swedish welfare estate the swedish
social democrats who came from the
working class
that is why they did not want civil
servants who mostly came from the middle
class to have
extra privileges
[Applause]
but france is not sweden we are talking
about a very elitist country to give you
an idea
almost all political leaders in this
country came from the same
university the ecole nationale de
administration i'm so sorry france this
is a school where the children of the
elites are trained to become politicians
in the last graduating class
only one percent of the students came
from a family of modest means in other
words as strange as it may sound the
land of liberty equality and fraternity
has
elitism engraved in its dna we could say
that france is enduring a permanent
revolution of republicans who deep down
want to be emperors so we are talking
about a welfare state with
privileges they are civil servants
career civil servants who have their job
guaranteed in the public administration
a luxury nowadays what's more unlike in
sweden where they are paid less
in france a civil servant is paid
practically the same if he or she
worked for a private company
but it is in retirement that the
privileges of french civil servants come
to the fore
whilst in private companies an
individual's salary over the last 25
years has taken into account to
calculate their pension the pensions of
civil servants only take into account
the final
six years of their working lives and of
course you can imagine all the bonuses
they receive
in their last years for example imagine
a person who starts his or her career as
a junior consultant and eventually
becomes a partner in the company it's
quite possible that his pension will be
smaller than that of any civil servant
when the average of his or her could be
calculated over the last 25 years and
now you may be wondering so what exactly
is the problem with all this
is it just that there are some groups
with better retirement conditions than
the rest well
the problem is that when anyone tries to
touch their pensions
all of those specific groups get up in
arms
it is the most logical thing to do i
mean imagine if youtubers were given two
thousand dollars a month just for our
pretty faces and
hopefully to fix our teeth if after 30
years some scoundrel tried to take that
privilege away for us well
you can be sure i won't be asking myself
if it was fair or not if they take away
my tooth money i will protest
[Music]
and all this explains why in france
every time a politician has wanted to
reform pensions the streets have turned
against him jack shirak wanted to put an
end to this special regime at first
but failed the union protests of 1995
are
mythical later sarkozy and hollande
pushed for some changes but they did not
dare to meddle with the privileged
groups even so whether right wing or
socialist both governments were
pressured by trade union mobilization
however what these past presidents had
to deal with
is nothing compared to now serious
altercations police charging against
demonstrators and you're probably
thinking but what about the macron
reform what has he done to provoke
stronger protests than those of 1995.
well we're gonna check that out right
now
[Music]
parasites
by now you may be wondering what is the
main change the macron is proposing well
nothing less than ending the 42 special
pension schemes the current system is
running at a loss and it is not in a
position to afford privileges in return
macron presents a universal points
system in which all workers will receive
points for their contribution and it
doesn't matter in which sector that
person
has worked these points will be worth
exactly the same for dancers or
mechanics civil servants or
god help us all youtubers so of course
despite the unions not knowing what the
reform would be like
and the workers having no idea how it
would affect them the protests against
the government began even before the
reform was presented
why well because all those with
privileges already knew that their sweet
sweet deal was coming to an end
there was also one thing we cannot
ignore with macron and his party la
republique on marche and that is that
both the left and the right are set to
bleed with macron because the situation
is the following after the government of
the socialist hollande which approved
significant cuts the working class
looked for answers in other political
forces therefore the mobilization
against the pension reform has created
an opportunity
for the left to take back the streets
despite other movements that escape its
control such as that of the yellow vests
so this debate has become a very good
opportunity for the unions who claim to
be the ones defending the people against
the government but also it's been good
for the extreme
right because
in the era of shirak or sarkozy
everything was very clear so who's
complaining the left-wing unions but
french politics today is more
complicated than all that both the
extreme left
and the extreme right are up in arms
against macron so while macron has a
stellar image outside france inside he
has the opposite to the left he is an
evil capitalist against labor rights for
the right he is a pro-greenie who wants
to do away with privileges that run as
deep as national identity so where do
all these feelings end up well
it's france so they end up with mass
protests so how has macron reacted to
this street response well his first move
was very conventional for a
representative of the new policy
six thousand policemen to repress the
unions and of course if you add in the
precedent of the yellow vests there are
terms when the matter has gotten out of
hand for the government
macron denounces police violence calls
for improved code of ethics
rfi pension reform pensions currently
account for 14
of france's gdp in the oecd the average
is percent
in the elections that brought him to the
elysee presidential palace he promised
that he would perform pensions and
although his approach was ambitious
macron has been softening his measures
the reform will not affect those over
45. in addition it will not apply to
train drivers over the age of 35
either and it will only affect dancers
at the paris opera who started working
there in 2022 but the biggest concession
carries a political coup macron wanted
to raise the age for retiring with a
full pension to 64 without penalty the
aim was to encourage people to retire
later and to tackle the system's deficit
which could reach 12
billion euros however the government
announced that it was giving up the
64-year threshold in exchange of passing
the ball
to others unions and employers have
three months to find a financial balance
by 2027
le monde however all of these
discussions came to a screeching halt
with the arrival of the pandemic both
the employers and the unions agreed with
the government to leave this issue until
the year we are now in
2021 in other words it is only now that
france hopes to resume this debate and
the political situation has changed
slightly
interestingly macron's approval ratings
have grown with the coronavirus right
now with 40
approval macron is france's most popular
present in 20 years
you heard me right 40 approval the
french ladies and gentlemen in fact he
could be the first president to repeat
his term
in this century now as much approval as
he has the polls of voting intentions
are not so favorable at the time of
making this video there were many polls
in which emmanuel macron
is tied with marianne le pen at the
moment his bill has already reached the
senate and has been met with
41 000 amendments no matter macron has a
sufficient majority to pass the pension
reform in the terms he deems
appropriate
so now the question is over to you do
you think macron will be able to pull
off his pension reform and
to what extent will impact his
re-election and just what will the
french
not riot over leave your answer in the
comments below as always don't forget
that we release new videos every week so
subscribe down there to the channel and
hit the little bell button so you don't
miss any of our updates if you like this
video please give it a thumbs up
and i'll see you in the next one and if
you want to learn more about politics
and hear even more of my lovely voice
you can join us at reconsider media we
have a podcast at reconsider
media.com podcast see you there